bonsoir à tous je suis ravi de vous
retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport l'émission
consacrée à l'actualité sportive dans le
département tout de suite le sommaire de
votre magazine
football le chesnay a réalisé l'exploit
de ce deuxième tour de la coupe de
france les lillois qui évolue en
excellence ont battu montreuil une
équipe de dh aux tirs au but le résumé
dans ce magazine taekwondo le trappistes
nisrine aybar a décroché le titre de
championne de france cadettes dont les
moins de 47 kg performance qui permet à
la sportive d'intégrer l'équipe de
france karting 1 m 23 23 kg 7 ans le duo
pour toi jean guilhas affole les
compteurs
le pilote vient de remporter les
nationales céleste karting et vient de
se qualifier pour les championnats du
monde portrait a su dans ce magazine
et puis nous parlerons également de la
réélection du président du district des
civils de football jean-pierre mur ayons
nous le recevrons dans quelques instants
dans ce magazine on commence donc ce
magazine par du football ont joué ce
week-end le deuxième tour de la coupe de
france le chesnais qui évolue en
excellence a réussi l'exploit d'éliminer
sur son terrain l'équipe de dh montreuil
l'une des plus belles pages de
l'histoire du club patrick jacques de
dixmude pour les images
le chesnay renverser l'ogre montreuil au
deuxième tour de la coupe de france les
chenilles 1 qui évolue dans le
championnat excellence se sont imposés
contre le 5e du championnat de dh dans
leur stade michaud ce match s'est résumé
à une histoire de penalty après avoir
réussi à ouvrir le score à la fin de la
première période les yvelinois ont
craqué en seconde période en commettant
une faute dans la surface
un partout à la fin du temps
réglementaire à la loterie des tirs au
but le che et l'emportent 3 0 on a une
équipe qui était supérieur à nous mais
sur le terrain ça c'est pas vu parce
qu'on a on a vraiment eu quatorze
joueurs
quinze joueurs même s'il ya un joueur
qui a un cap a pu jouer qu'un joueur
conques ont participé à cette aventure
on l'a préparé et voilà donc on l'a on
voulait bien finir c'est l'objectif
voilà c'est ce que c'est pas nous qui
avons été plus à la hauteur que ils ont
fait leur match ils nous ont mis en
danger etc
mais nous on a rivalisé on voulait
rivaliser voilà on a voulu rester au
contact le plus longtemps possible
on a un avantage ouverte d'ouvrir le
score après voilà ils ont ils ont fait
leur match nous on a fait un gros match
mais on est capable ça veut dire qu'on
est capable de le faire maintenant sur
toute une saison c'est ce qu'il faut
retenir aussi c'est un match compliqué
face une équipe de dh qui était pas
facile à jouer on a réussi à marquer en
premier c'est assez important
ensuite son revenu sur un penalty assez
litigieux mais bon on a on a réussi à
tenir grâce aux consignes du coach faut
les féliciter et voilà on est on est on
est on est content de la qualification
mais va falloir continuer dans cette
coupe de france 4e du championnat
excellence cette année les chesnaysiens
vise à présent une épopée en coupe de
france lors de la saison 2016 2017
on va essayer forcément d'aller au 4e ou
5e tour pour aller un peu plus loin
après ça dépend du tirage
voilà mais les joueurs ont montré qu'ils
sont capables de faire plus que ce
qu'ils ont fait toute la saison voilà
c'est ça que ce sac je retiens et on va
s'appuyer là dessus pour préparer la
saison prochaine ça va être compliqué de
répondre maintenant parce qu'on est dans
le forez mais maintenant qu'on a sorti
une dh sont se rend compte qu'on a la
possibilité d'aller plus loin dans cette
coupe de france le 3e tour de la coupe
de france se jouera le premier week-end
de septembre on ne connaît pas encore
l'adversaire du chéné pour cette
rencontre
on reste dans le football jean-pierre
meurillon vient d'être réélu à la tête
du district des yvelines de football
pour quatre ans pour nous parler de son
actualité de ces projets ainsi que de
l'euro en france nous recevrons sur ce
plateau
bonsoir changèrent noyon alors avant de
parler de votre élection va parler tout
de suite de la coupe de france et de cet
exploit du chéné est ce que vous en
pensez de cette exploiter moi j'aimerais
jouer toujours lorsqu'un club bon
résultat là il ya le chesnay certes mais
la semaine d'avant il y avait trappe
son souvenir aux 6 tentés de croire et
puis et puis la saison dernière les
exploits de menthe qui ne s'est fait
éliminé que par nantes faut s'en
souvenir
un stade très très avancé les lambris
fiction 16e de finale c'est quand même
en huitièmes de finale devient de fait
c'est quand même c'est quand même c'est
un exploit
moi j'aimerais jouer toujours lorsqu'un
club yvelinois va très loin en coupe de
france parce que c'est révélateur du
travail qui est fait par les clubs aussi
ce n'était que le deuxième tour mais
finalement c'est quand même un exploit
oui c'est un exploit on peut dire bah
oui oui tout à fait il ya une belle
coupe des yvelines également qui a été
organisée il ya deux semaines avec la
victoire de maurepas contre lui mais
devant plus d'une centaine de supporters
c'était une réussite pour cette coupe
tout à fait 7 est une réussite
tout s'est bien passé j'ai coutume de
dire qu'évidemment à chaque à chaque
fois qu'il ya un match en coupe c'est un
match à élimination directe y en a un
qui gagne qui perd mais même ceux qui
ont perdu se sont très bien tenues les
choses se sont bien passées on était
dans un esprit sportif dans un beau
complexe nous étions un plaisir et mord
pas sa première fois sauf à vérifier
c'est la première fois qu'un tel elle
apprend la france les deux remportent
les deux coupes
et alors maurepas je rebondis nous
étions hier toute la journée avec la
journée nationale des débutants qui se
passait à maurepas et donc on a eu
l'occasion d'en reparler hier avec le
président de maurepas et c'était c'est
bien c'est bien le football se porte
bien dans les yvelines
cette coupe doit continuer à exister ou
les yvelines elle doit continuer à
exister ce qu'elle apporte
alors il ya des débats là dessus il ya
des gens qui disent ah bah oui mais
faudrait laisser laisser les équipes ne
pas enfin le peuvent participer à cette
coupe que ce que les équipes qui
participent au championnat des yvelines
et donc ça veut dire que les clubs qui
jouent en ligue ne participent à cette
compétition faudra qu'il ya un débat
là-dessus bien il ya un débat en cours
et on fera trancher les clubs
si nécessaire le moment d'une trappe
pour versailles pour y intégrer la coupe
des idées elle allait éventuellement
mais ça il faut que ce soit des clubs
qu'ils décident au même vous avez été
élu je disais précédemment à la tête du
district quelle est votre réaction tout
simplement par rapport à cette
réélection s'étaient attendus à ben vous
serez une élection
une élection ce sont les électeurs qui
décident donc on a eu effectivement avec
mon équipe on a eu un résultat très très
intéressant on a vu 92 50% des voix même
si avec une liste qui pourrait il aurait
pu y avoir beaucoup plus de votre contre
nous ça nous conforte dans l'idée que la
façon dont on gère le district c'est la
façon dont les clubs souhaitent qu'on
gère le district c'est à dire de façon
collégiale en étant à leur écoute j'ai
un maître mot là dessus j'ai été lui
habitants pour la première fois et ma
première déclaration était celle-là
c'est de dire il faut être à l'écouté
des clubs et travailler avec eux dans la
concertation
donc les coûts de la concertation et
ensuite in fine est la décision par les
clubs
c'est pas parce que nous sommes élus que
nous prônons nous toutes les décisions
les positions les plus importantes en
effet prendre par les clubs et c'est
votre côté peut-être un peu populaire
qui vous a permis d'être d'être réélu je
suis pas certain de choix populaire vous
savez chaque fois que le var le niveau
du terrain par exemple oui ben je vois
beaucoup de mal je suis souvent sur les
terrains le dimanche
mais c'est vrai que chaque fois que le
district prend une décision bas il ya un
club qui estime que
on n'a pas pris la bonne et l'autre
estime qu'on a pris la bonne mais que
c'était normal puisque c'est lui qui
avait raison enfin je schématise je
caricature un peu mais c'est un peu ça
mais nous notre rôle est de faire en
sorte que le football se joue dans de
bonnes conditions dans les yvelines
d'aider les clubs être à leur écoute
travailler dans le sens du football qui
intéresse les clubs vous sentez qu'il ya
un véritable dialogue entre vous et les
hommes de terrain c'est souvent ce qu'on
reproche aux districts est-ce que vous
avez ce sentiment là également
ah ben moi j'ai le sentiment inverse
j'ai le sentiment que effectivement les
clubs par le passé considérer que le
district ne faisait que percevoir des
amendes et donner des sanctions à
infliger des sanctions et je pense que
maintenant
depuis maintenant plusieurs années ça
fait maintenant trois ou quatre ans au
mois de mars avril on réunit tous les
clubs on leur présente ce qu'on a
l'intention de leur présenter le jour de
l'assemblée générale on dialogue avec
eux quelquefois même on modifie la façon
dont on envisager les choses alors alors
leurs contacts et ensuite ce sont les
clubs qui votent notre assemblée
générale c'était l'autre semaine à noisy
le roi et avait 18 votes différents et
les clubs se sont prononcés ce 18 fois
en disant oui mon disant non et c'est
toute cette eau qui gère le district va
aborder le thème de la sécurité vous
avez constaté les progrès cette saison
vous la sécurité dans le passé eu des
problèmes notamment à chanteloup les
vignes
il ya quelques années de ça cette année
vous avez sentiment que qui a du progrès
alors depuis quelques années quand on
regarde le pourcentage de baigts willy à
des incidents hors faits de jeu je parle
pas du du carton rouge parce qu'il ya eu
une main etc
on n'essaie pas là dessus mais hors
faits de jeu on s'aperçoit qu'on a
contrairement à ce que beaucoup pensent
on a de moins en moins
deux problèmes il ya quelques années on
était à 2,20 pour cent des matchs qui se
passait avec des incidents maintenant on
en est à 8 lors c'est encore trop mais
il n'empêche que on progresse on va dans
le bon sens sur une progression et au
niveau des amendes
vous mettez des amendes également quand
il ya des cartons rouges par exemple oui
alors est-ce que les cartouches doivent
être plus sanctionnés c'est à dire que
quand il ya quand y'a une exclusion il
ya une sanction qui est personnel aux
joueurs c'est à dire celui qui a commis
quelques mis la faute
et puis à une sanction qui est infligé
au club le montant des amendes n'a pas
varié depuis huit ans c'est un signe il
n'a pas varié depuis huit ans et puis il
faut dire aussi que notre budget certes
il ne se rendra pas dans les quatre
prochaines années de votre mandat ah non
les nôtres notre intention est de tenir
compte du fait que les clubs ont des
difficultés et notre relais et d'éviter
de leur encre et d'autre part tranché
quand on continue de ne pas augmenter
tous les l'ensemble des tarifs du
district n'augmenteront pas au niveau
des joueurs justement des sanctions est
ce qu'il faut encore plus travailler
avec avec les clubs pour pour améliorer
l'esprit on va dire des équipes alors
nous faisons beaucoup dans ce domaine de
la prévention par exemple beaucoup de
prévention nous sommes aussi il faut le
rappeler
nous avons une rencontre périodique avec
nos collègues présents comme des comités
départementaux de rugby de handball et
basket-ball ça s'appelle le s p 78 et
l'esprit sportif partager et 78 et on
travaille entre nous pour voir comment
les autres comités départementaux gers
est question de de violence et
d'incivilités se met in fine est notre
rôle est aussi quand il ya faute est
bien de sanctionner c'est pas le plus
agréable dans notre rôle mais on est
aussi là pour ça
un point positif pour le district des
yvelines le football féminin
je crois qu'il y avait eu une
augmentation multiplié par quatre le
nombre de licenciées féminines a
augmenté par 4 200 à 400 licenciés en
quatre ans c'est bien ça alors en fait
on est passé de 972 il ya deux ans à
1609 cette saison c'est l'augmentation
est de 65 % en deux ans et globalement
sur les quatre dernières années la ligue
de paris dont nous faisons partie à
augmenter l'effectif de 160% 160%
tiennent là où il y avait 100 joueuses
maintenant il y en a deux cent soixante
mais c'est pas qu'une question de
chiffres il faut aussi que les jeunes
filles qui viennent qui viennent jouer
au foot bien soit accueillie dans les
clubs et je suis en train mois de jeu
moi je milite pour que
il existe désormais un championnat
senior dans les yvelines
comme d'ailleurs dans les autres
districts donc on y travaille la ligue
est en train de réfléchir sur le sujet
et je pense qu'il faut il faut qu'on
fasse ça les quelques années on a créé
des plateau u11 et bien quelques années
après
deux ans après on a fait des plateaux
u13 cette année on a créé un challenge u
et puis les u16 val de vienne 17 u 18 et
c'est donc il faut qu'on en fasse de
l'augmentation du nombre de licenciés il
faut que l'offre départementale de
football féminin soit élargi c'est
l'avenir du football féminin sont bien
en tout cas ça se développe de façon
très intéressante on a on a depuis le
début de l'année civile dans le cadre de
l'euro avec la lettre de la direction
départementale de la cohésion sociale
nous avons organisé plein de choses dans
le football féminin
on en a fait un mort pas d'huile en
cours à carrières-sur-seine attrape à
elancourt à poissy achères notre finale
nos finales féminines auront lieu à
cheikh lente cadre d'une journée du foot
féminin
on fait ça depuis maintenant deux ans
l'année par des précédents s'étaient
rendre esi et on a de plus en plus de
jeunes filles qui viennent dans ces
journées pour pour jouer au foot tout
simplement vous êtes plutôt favorable on
voit que par exemple la trappe
il ya un club qui s'est créée un voisin
bretonneux également à montigny est ce
que vous êtes plutôt favorable à la
propagation de plusieurs clubs la
création de plusieurs structures
féminines dans plusieurs clubs ou plutôt
un gros pôle pour regrouper toutes les
meilleures choses alors un gros pôle ça
pose un problème de proximité
parce que quand ce sont des joueuses qui
ont 18 ou 19 ans ou quelles sont ses
dires elle se déplace elle son mobile
entre guillemets quand ce sont des
petites quand elles ont 11 ans 12 ans 13
ans ce qui est important c'est qu'elles
puissent jouer pas loin de chez elle est
actuellement on peut faire de la mixité
jusqu'à 15 ans jusqu'à ce que la jeune
fille et 15 ans au delà la jeune fille
qui a fait du foot depuis plusieurs
années
si elle habite dans un bassin de
population où il ya des équipes
féminines et des clubs féminins elle
continue le footsie par contre elle est
le premier club féminin est loin c'est
compliqué malheureusement les
abandonnent le foot donc je pense qu'il
faut qu'il faut les deux choses je pense
que chez les seniors il ya moyen de
regrouper probablement mais chez les
petites il faut qu'il ya une notion de
proximité entre le domicile des joueurs
et puis l'endroit où tu peux jouer au
foot on va parler de l'euro forcément
c'est l'euro en ce moment au niveau
local quel est l'impact d'une
compétition comme le championnat
d'europe
au niveau des clubs locaux alors
l'impact
je vais prendre l'exemple de mon
équilibre autonome qui organise à
compter de la fin de la semaine une
semaine
il ajoute le village foot absolument
auquel nous nous allons un tout petit
peu participé on sera là on sera présent
avec des arbitres le jour d'été au
tournoi samedi prochain à dimanche
prochain mais un peu partout il ya eu
des actions qui ont été menées par par
des clubs et ou par des municipalités on
les a toujours encouragé il y en a un
certain nombre qui ont été labellisées
dans le cadre du dispositif tout spray
qui a été mis en place par l'est par la
fédération et par le ministère chargé
des sports
manifestement il ya un engouement pour
le lot il se fâche chez nous il y aura
plus de licenciés à la rentrée écoutez
ça va dépendre en partie des résultats
ni qui commence équipe de france pas
seulement je dirais pas seulement des
résultats de son comportement aussi
parce que les résultats sportifs mais il
ya aussi le l'image que véhiculent
l'équipe de france là elle est pour
l'instant excellente jeu mais on ne peut
que s'en réjouir
et c'est vrai que ça ça amène en général
lorsque l'équipe de france se comporte
bien dans tous les sports c'est comme ça
quand le monde se comporte bien quand
quand il contient les français qui vont
loin dans le tennis etc où on espère que
les guides de france ira très loin et
que ça nous amènera des licenciés pour
permettre aux jeunes qui veulent jouer
au foot de le faire on va terminer cet
entretien par un pronostic qui va gagner
l'euro selon nous mais je pense que ce
sera la meilleure équipe
puis je pense que l'équipe de france
elle et elle est pas loin d'être parmi
les meilleurs je pense qu'on a on a une
vraie chance que vous savez le sport
reste le sport le poteau le peut
renvoyer le ballon le faire entrer dans
le but
c'est aussi ce qui est intéressant dans
le sport c'est pas toujours scientifique
après il ya l'incertitude comme on dit
un certain temps nous avons voté pour
l'équipe de france ça oui absolument
merci vous voulez passer sur ce plateau
bonne continuation pour votre mandat
après cette large page football coup de
projecteur sur le taekwondo une jeune
trappistes brille actuellement dans le
taekwondo nisrine et barras est devenue
championne de france en mai à lyon il
rejoindra l'équipe de france pour le
prochain championnat d'europe à bucarest
en septembre les images sont signés
patrick jacques de dixmude nisrine et
bart raison est l'étoile montante du
taekwondo en france la sportive qui
s'entraînent quatre fois par semaine au
club de trappes a décroché le 14 mai
dernier à lyon le titre de championne de
france dans la catégorie cadette moins
de 47 kg je voulais gagner que j allais
cette fois c'est pour gagner pas pour
perdre et je voulais absolument remo
première
ce titre n'est pas une surprise pour les
dirigeants et coach du club qui l'ont vu
évoluer pendant six ans dans la
structure pour être honnête on on l'a
mise est sûre elle vous pensez vraiment
que pouvaient rêver ce qu'au beau être
championne de france dans le techno plus
on les grands et fin
donc automatiquement la de la longe et
assez bien s'en servir
allez assez doué techniquement la des
bols technique assez écoutée elle lâche
pas la faire à la détermination à va
jusqu'au bout de ce qu'elle fait cette
victoire lui a permis de décrocher une
sélection en équipe de france pour le
prochain championnat d'europe qui se
tiendra en septembre à bucarest en
roumanie suis très contente très fier de
moi je voulais un jour à intégrer
l'équipe de france evra s'est réalisé
j'ai travaillé dur pour arriver à ça à
pouvoir aller dans l'équipe de france et
l'équipe de france prochaine étape pour
la jeune trappistes un titre de
championne d'europe avant d'essayer
d'atteindre son rêve une qualification
pour les jeux olympiques 2024
on reste dans la catégorie jeune prodige
avec le pilote de kart jimmy
le jeune pilote de karting j milhas
affole les compteurs à seulement sept
ans il est un as du karting évinois déjà
remporté plusieurs courses dont la
national séries karting ce week-end il
vient de se qualifier pour les
championnats du monde qui se dérouleront
dans trois mois nous le recevons sur ce
plateau avec son frère jonathan hélias
qui est également son coach alors
quelles sont tes impressions
j'ai mis après cette victoire c'est bien
meilleur
c'est très bien si magique si tous
étaient contents oui c'était attendu
cette victoire de génie ce week-end
alors on a beaucoup préparé ont préparé
ce championnat on a été affaire voulait
pas mal le p'tit djimy
il a été chercher la victoire vraiment
en partant de la neuvième place orontes
en premier et donc maintenant il est
qualifié pour le championnat du monde
l'un des pilotes les plus jeunes de
l'histoire de deux mobiles année aux
championnats du monde et c'est une
surprise ou pas du tout qu'il a été les
gagner finalement ils gagnent un peu
tout le temps en ce moment mais il gagne
un petit peu tout le temps c'est vrai
que un jour il nous a dit qu'il voulait
faire du karting comme moi qui qui fait
du karting plus jeune qui est champion
de france vice-champions d'europe
il m'a dit jo je veux absolument faire
du karting
donc à partir de ce moment là je lui
achetais venu acheter un karting
j'ai monté mon team et on a commencé à
le faire rouler un petit peu a essayé de
trouver le budget à votre la famille et
les amis qui nous ont aidés on a mis
dans les quartiers la conte vraiment
commencé à gagner toutes les courses
mais qu'est ce qui t'a donné envie de
faire du karting
j'ai mis ce que j'ai envie que d'avoir
des coupes change et avoir plein de cook
si c'est billon et je crois que tu as
rencontré un pilote mercedes
esteban au con je crois qu'ils et ombres
ton parent également et c'est lui qui
t'a donné envie aussi de faire du
karting c'est lui vraiment ce qu'il
admire cds qui lui a donné des conseils
pour ces maquis pour progresser ouais il
lui a aussi donné des conseils
et quand il était tout petit déjà à la
maison comment je revenais avec mes
coupes c'est vrai qu'ils et je veux des
coupes je veux des coupes je vais gagner
je veux faire du karting comme toi donc
maintenant on fait tout pour l'entraîner
le maximum possible pour que vraiment ça
ça devienne un champion et que le
champion devienne un jour une légende et
à kehl à quel âge il a commencé
le karting alors il a commencé il ya
tout juste sept mois faites moi voilà
donc ils viennent déjà tout wall again
to il est avec des enfants qu'ils soient
âgés de deux à trois ans de plus que lui
donc c'est vraiment le petit rookie qui
gagne qui gagne toutes les compètes qui
en veut qui a la hargne jusqu'au dernier
moment
il est vraiment impressionnant même
c'est pas parce que je dis ça parce que
c'est mon petit frère mais en jetant un
coup d'oeil extérieur c'est vraiment
très très impressionnant de voir un
stage là un pilote est allé aussi vite
et s'adapter très vite chimie tu pensais
aller aussi vite
oui depuis qu'a commencé oui je sentais
que tu pouvais gagner autant de coupes
et toi quand tu te lances dans une
compétition dans une course tu dis quoi
au début la course et du ghana et
quelles sont ses qualités et ses défauts
ce qu'il en a quelques uns quand même
des défauts exactement ce qu'ils ont ce
qu'on est en train de travailler
d'ailleurs donc c'est vrai qu'on bon des
fois il est il dit les jeunes c'est le
rookie donc ça arrive qu'il est un petit
peu d'appréhension avant la course mais
une fois qu'on a calmé cette
appréhension c'est vrai que jimmy
reprend le dessus
arrivé une des ses qualités c'est avoir
la hargne se bat jusqu'au bout jusqu'à
temps que le drapeau d'arrivée n'est pas
passé on voit jimmy se battre c'est pas
donc c'est vraiment un serment génial
j'ai mis tu t'entraînes combien de fois
par semaine
quelle foi une foi une foi parce que tu
vas l'école à côté oui et du coup tu
t'en donne quand même temps chaque fois
que tu vas tu vas sur sa queue pour
entraîner et vous entrez sur quel
circuit du coup donc s'entraîne vraiment
dans toute la france dans toute la
france sur un circuit où il va y avoir
des compétitions prochainement aussi
c'est vrai que jimmy vont essayer de le
faire rouler le plus possible sans le
faire louper l'école il a un point fort
c'est qu'à l'école il travaille très
très bien et c'est vraiment un des
meilleurs élèves de sa classe
donc on fait tout pour jamie tu roules à
plus de 100 kilomètres heure je crois si
je me trompe pas sur ton 125 cm tube tu
prends des risques dans les virages face
aux autres pilotes
est-ce que tu as peur de quelque chose
qui n'a peur de rien vous avez ce
sentiment là également dans son frère
c'est pas une fois il est venu me voir
il m'a dit jo j'ai peur dé finir
deuxième c'est vrai que il veut vraiment
gagner
il veut je pense que oui sa plus grosse
peur c'est de ne pas être sur le podium
ne pas réfléchir aller chercher les
victoires quoi donc
donc voilà j'ai mis je vais à présent
présenté trois pilotes
tu vas me dire lequel tu préfères et
quel est ton modèle on commence par
michael schumacher sept fois champion du
monde
on continue par ayrton senna trois fois
champion du monde avec 65 pole position
est également lewis hamilton qu'on
voyait juste précédemment à l'écran
triple champion du monde et deuxième au
championnat du monde actuellement qui
est ton pilotes préférés
hamilton est pourquoi parce que il a
commencé le karting et cani tout du coi
j'aime bien lewis hamilton c'est un bon
modèle pour leur part jimmy
c'est un très bon modèle après ce que
nous fait jimmy actuellement c'est vrai
que personne ne l'a jamais fait de toute
l'histoire du sport automobile
arrivé à sept ans plusieurs colonies ça
m'étonne c'est à dire peut-être pas plus
fort mais c'est à dire que je progresse
plus précoce voilà il a gagné vraiment
c'est du jamais vu de voir un enfant de
7 ans rookie gagner la haine escales
donc la nationale serris karting avec
tous les meilleurs pilotes français ou à
la fin il n'y en n'aura qu'a donc jimmy
qui sera retenu pour aller aux
championnats du monde
les quelles sont les prochaines étapes
produit alors déjà la prochaine étape
c'est le championnat de france qui se
déroulera à mirecourt donc essayer de
gagner le championnat français notre
objectif cette année en tant que rookie
est ensuite allé au championnat du monde
et l'année prochaine
commencer un petit peu a roulé en
international gmi quel serait ton plus
grand rêve alors formule 1 tu crois que
c'est possible tel potentiel tu le sens
oui on te souhaite en tout cas merci à
tous de dépasser sur ce bateau on vous
souhaite
on souhaite évidemment à jimmy de
réussir c'est plus roanne grand rêve
merci à vous on passe maintenant on
reste de l'actualité y vino à ça on
commence cette rubrique part du football
et plus précisément l'euro qui se joue
en france les bleus qui s'entraînent à
clairefontaine dans les yvelines se sont
imposés 2-1 dans les ultimes minutes
contre la roumanie pour leur entrée dans
la compétition avec cette victoire
l'équipe de france a pris la tête du
groupe a avec devant la suisse prochain
match pour les bleus mercredi prochain
marseille contre l'albanie
l'idée deschamps devrait reconduire la
même équipe contre la roumanie avec
notamment dimitri payet et olivier
giroud toujours au chapitre
or aux deux équipes étrangères ans pour
camp de base les yvelines pour cette
édition 2016 l'irlande a choisi
versailles la russie croatie sur scène
jeudi dernier les irlandais se sont
entraînés au stade mont boron devant
plus de mille supporters déchaînés les
enfants des écoles avoisinantes ont pu
assister un mini match contre l'équipe
des remplaçants et titulaires et voir la
star de l'équipe robbie keane on écoute
un supporter alors comme on disait comme
on disait ça fait du bien de voir une
autre équipe jouer que que l'équipe de
france se serait que je suis habitué
plus à aller voir les joueurs de
l'équipe de france jouer donc là de voir
l'équipe d'irlande
ça fait plaisir vraiment ça fait plaisir
plus en plus bonne ambiance avec les
enfants le club
dick ans c'était génial pour l'euro les
irlandais sont dans le groupe e le
groupe e baptisé le groupe de la mort
avec la belgique d'éden hazard l'italie
de bouffonne et la suède de zlatan
ibrahimovic qu'ils affrontent en ce
moment au stade de france
un groupe de la mort difficile mais le
sélectionneur martin o'neill micro pour
brive en d2 nous allons tenter de donner
le meilleur de nous mêmes et je pense
que les autres équipes ont tout donné
tant qu'aide d'accéder au prochain tour
de la compétition
mais toutes les équipes dans notre
groupe toutes les équipes de la
compétition vont tenter d'accomplir leur
objectif la victoire finale à 18h55
l'équipe d'irlande est toujours obtient
toujours en échec 0 0 à l'équipe de
suède au stade de france
moins médiatique l'équipe de russie
s'est entraîné au stade omnisport de
croatie a sur scène ce mercredi devant
plus d'une centaine de supporters venus
notamment du club de football local
les joueurs ont réalisé une petite
opposition sur un demi terrain et ont
également signé des autographes à la fin
de la session
on écoute les supporters présents sur
place chez 10 joueurs
mais des joueurs très forts tu faisais
beaucoup de passes et qui marquait bien
les buts ça me fait plaisir que nous
cessons nationale viennent s'entraîner
dans ma ville et sur le terrain où je
joue tous à dire que tous les noirs
voient ça me fait plaisir de voir des
pros dans ma vie loi c'est la fin de
cette vie de sport merci d'avoir suivi
vous pourrez retrouver cette émission
rep et sur notre site internet et sur
youtube très belle soirée sur tv fil 78